new information on a high-stakes mystery
we've been covering for years now the
c.i.a says that most cases of the
neurological illness known as havana
syndrome remember that were not were not
caused by a foreign adversary senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has the latest on all this
catherine i think this was surprising
news for a lot of people good morning
tony it was for many good morning the
cia has released new interim findings
overnight on hundreds of reported cases
of havana syndrome ultimately ruling out
russia cuba or any other foreign group
as the cause of most of these illnesses
instead the majority of reports can be
reasonably explained by medical
conditions or environmental and
technical factors including previously
undiagnosed illnesses after a cluster of
cases was first reported in cuba u.s
diplomats and personnel stationed
overseas said they experienced havana
syndrome symptoms including in china
austria and vietnam some told cbs news
they heard ringing or loud piercing
sounds and felt intense pressure in the
face with pain nausea and dizziness a
recent study conducted for the state
department found the most plausible
cause was directed pulsed radio
frequency energy the cia said about two
dozen priority cases remain unexplained
and the focus of active investigation
russian and cuban officials have
consistently denied involvement gail
all right catherine thank you very much